it's time for et's social study a quick
look at everything your favorite stars
have been posting online
Bella Thorne went super red and green
seemingly a neon twist on those classic
holiday colors meanwhile Lindsay Lohan
also darkened her locks and a Azalea
seemingly went blonder and bolder the
rapper rocked a blazer with no shirt
yeah we yet yeah Nick Jonas is also
flashing his abs and huge arms he shared
his new men's fitness cover and Neil
Patrick Harris snapped this sneaky pic
of Bill Murray while on a flight home
from Berlin and we just got engaged
we've known each other for for more than
a year now
uh-huh for she listens and who proposed
you or him I proposed yeah yeah that's
so sweet
Ricky Martin announced his engagement
and Las Vegas residency on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show he shared this
black-and-white selfie from backstage
yeah that made life better and a Big
Bang Theory star Jim Parsons is also
celebrating love he instagrammed this
throwback pic with his boyfriend at todd
Spiewak they're celebrating 14 years
together
Jim captioned the shot the best thing
that ever happened to me
no contest
you